I do want to shine a lot light on what
you've been doing because I know you
were in Mexico City and now you are
helming relief for the earthquake can
you tell me what you're working on and a
message you'd like to send everybody
watching yes please we put together a
crowdfunding campaign to support those
who lost everything after the
earthquakes in Mexico we had three
earthquakes in less than 20 days and the
destruction is massive and we need a lot
of a lot of help basically so if you're
not in Mexico and you and you want to be
part of this solidarity you you can go
to donate dot or maze come slash Mexico
and make a donation it's gonna it's
gonna make a difference for those who
really need you today we're gonna be
distributing that money in civil efforts
you know it's not gonna go to the
government everyone is very worried
about that in my country which is such a
corrupt country no one trusts the
government and what we're doing is is
making sure this money goes to those
efforts happening already that needs
help that need a little extra push you
know we're gonna focus in reconstructing
and giving support to the to the people
that lost everything so if you can join
you're more than welcome again donate
dot amaze come slash Mexico it's simple
and and we'll be we'll be telling you
what we do with the money you know it's
not it's it's gonna be transparent and
clean
[Music]
you